you know here at the daily wire we've
had many inter-faith battles
ben everyone knows as a jew drew is an
anglican
jeremy is a protestant as he describes
it and
i believe he's styled as a minor deity
himself and then
matt walsh and i are catholics never
have we had an
intra faith battle but we get this
question all the time people ask
who's the better catholic at the daily
wire which is very confusing because in
the catholic faith
we're so concerned with guilt that you
know in a way like the worst catholic is
kind of the best catholic
it's very complicated in any case we are
going to
finally take up this listener question
we will have
a catholic face-off
yeah can i let me just i just want to
say for the record um
that i just to be totally honest i
turned down this bit like three times
uh i they kept asking me about it asked
me months ago and i said i don't want to
do that
because i'm terrible at trivia and
i'm about to get demolished here and i i
i do not agree with the premise
which is that if you don't know trivia
that means you're a bad catholic because
like you already mentioned it yeah the
best catholic is the person who hates
themselves
the most and that has to be me so i
already won
but now we're gonna find out who knows
more trivia and um trivia is just not my
bag so
i that's why i kept saying no can we do
a different but but they kept coming
back so now
now i'm here so so the rule the ground
rules are what we're gonna um
drew's gonna he came up with the
questions even though he's not catholic
he he came up with the catholic trivia
questions
and uh we're gonna play those and then
we'll have 30 seconds to write down our
answers
on these uh white boards so that's
that's the one good thing is we have
these
uh i've always wanted to do a thing
where i write answers on whiteboard so
that's the one good thing about this
and we'll write our answer on the white
whiteboard and then um
and then at the end the loser has to
what
the loser reads an ad for the winner
on their social media platforms i take
it
and the winner that goes to heaven i
don't know i i haven't brushed up on my
theology recently but i think i guess
the winner gets their ad read
on the platform i'm i'm game well not
really i'm not really game but we'll do
it i'm here
all right drew take it away all right
we're here with the catholic face-off to
determine who
is the better catholic matt walsh or
michael knowles
it's matt walsh but we still have to ask
the questions and go through the motions
here are the questions in january 1959
pope john
the 23rd that's i think that's what
xx111 means
shocked the world when he announced the
creation of this
ecumenical council
okay i'm ready
and the answer is vatican ii or as
knowles calls it
the great transgression
drew just knows me too we we both little
parents at the same time
okay oh okay sorry
there it is the ecclesiastical boogaloo
yeah
this famous catholic who holds two
academy awards for the same film in 1996
has been quoted as saying god is the
only one who knows how many children we
should have
and we should be ready to accept them
one can't decide for oneself
who comes into this world and who
doesn't that decision
doesn't belong to us a catholic
academy award said that yeah i don't i
actually don't know who that is
i'm impressed with this person whoever
it is yeah i like them
um famous catholic
with academy awards i don't
how many famous catholics are there with
academy awards uh
okay i i guess i'll i'll go with the
only one i can even think of
yeah i don't like my answer at all here
but i'm also my writing is illegible so
i have that
gone oh mel gibson i put robert de niro
is that that's de niro catholic oh he's
probably i'm sure he's bad because he's
italian so i just assume that he's
catholic
that's mel gibson who forgot to mention
you're only supposed to do it with one
wife
see i i didn't even realize that robert
mel gibson i thought he was some sort of
weird
sect i didn't think he was actually
catholic he yeah he's kind of trended a
little bit like
uh more uh the term is sede vacantest
you know in recent years
but he you know the reason i thought it
might be gibson is because
you know he's pretty pretty traditional
and that statement where it's basically
like have as many kids as you can that's
pretty
that's pretty trad in 1981 the vatican
observatory set up a second
research center for astronomical
observation
in this american city
astronomical observation
what is this city that would have i do i
do like that the vatican is just
after they gave up the papal states
they're just coming in and like pulling
off different pieces of other countries
including our own
but oh my gosh i don't know
this is a city we're supposed to pick
all right okay
the answer is tucson arizona and anyone
who doesn't know that of course
uh has to spend time in purgatory that's
catholic doctrine
yeah i chose basically the dumbest place
to put it an observatory for
which would be new york so i think i was
wrong about that i chose austin texas
because i know there is an observatory
there but i visited it
and i have to tell you it it was very
hipster it was not very catholic
until the papacy moved to the vatican in
1377 the pope resided at this location
on the other side of rome
oh hmm in rome
i think i know the answer here
i'm just going to name the only other
place i can even think of
uh it was lorenzo's bar and grill uh the
wings were found no it wasn't it was
later in palace later in palace
i said palatine hill i actually put
ladder in palace
it's hard to read but um i wrote it very
quickly
i wrote it very quickly but that's
actually says ladder and palace right
here so
is that in koine greek perhaps or yeah
in fact yeah i wrote it
in several different languages all at
once
to be the pope's bodyguard an applicant
must be catholic
single male between the ages of 19 and
30 at least five feet eight and a half
inches tall
and a citizen of this country
all right answer switzerland and of
course
to wear that outfit you have to be gay
yeah i said i said italy so this is
going about as well as i thought
it would this is the whole reason i
didn't want to do this bit
well you you did get uh lorenzo's bar
and grill or whatever the answer the
last one was i got one right
i'm gonna count that one
in ancient times scribes copied books by
hand
on scrolls and paper or printmakers
printed texts from hand-carved wooden
blocks
before this catholic inventor's creation
changed
the world
oh my god can't believe the name is
escaping this one of the most important
people that's ever lived
all right play the answer before the
name comes back oh gosh this is driving
me crazy play it now
i need to get at least one i need to
have at least one point on the board
here oh no
the it's the answer of course is al gore
no it's johannes gutenberg gutenberg
oh my gosh i had guggenheim in my head i
actually got gutenberg
that's very basically says it
brutal in 2006 cardinal
ercilio tonini denounced this former
catholic's upcoming music tour
as a blasphemous challenge to the faith
and a profanation
of the cross
former like uh i feel pretty good about
this one because i want to say bono but
he still considers himself catholic
okay all right let's see i don't see
bono being denounced yeah although he
should be he should be
though the answer is madonna
all right the madonna but madonna
so is this even right now no way it's
even it's like seven to two
in 1961 the government of brazil
declared this catholic a national
treasure
brazil is that it how the hell are we
supposed to know that
yeah i don't i don't i'm i'm thinking of
like
old historical figures but i just don't
i don't think any of this is right
all right i think i got it the answer of
course is pele
who else
was it actually paylight oh come on
i drew one of those cool fancy s's that
uh
can i at least get half a point for that
i was going to say cortez
because i think that'd be that was
before political correctness came in and
ruined everything but
no pele wow okay born
in 1473 this catholic astronomer
practice medicine without a medical
degree
astronomer practiced medicine 1473.
uh the answer is nicholas copernicus yes
okay hold on
nicholas so i didn't finish writing it
but i did get the cop
i think it's pretty clear unless i was
talking about someone else
no we can't count wait i come on i was
right i had galileo but uh
you can't count who what other cop i'm
not talking about like
like a buddy cop movie belt gibson again
coppola was born in 1473
that's that's some bush league stuff
okay if you can prove
that he went by the nickname pop if
people just talk
hey cop what's up man that is i i'm
gonna pro i'm taking this up
to the judicial authorities of this game
that's outrageous
what is the only historically black and
catholic university in the united states
hmm what was the question
historically black and white is the only
historically black and catholic
university in the united states
hmm
hang on i got i know i just gotta i
gotta text real quick oh yeah yeah
it's coming in yeah i it's my wife's
text me about
yeah it's really dinner or something
historically black and catholic
university in the united states
i don't know the name of that many the
sad thing is i'm cheating right now and
i still can't find the answer
this is why i barely graduated high
school what is that
the answer is xavier university
yeah you could have given me like
all the time in the world i never would
have gotten that well i i was googling
it and i still
didn't immediately come up in the google
results so
what was the greatest distance from
vatican city where communion
was taken
ever well i don't understand the
question
what was the greatest distance from
vatican city where communion
was taken i don't what i understand the
premise of the question
great the greatest distance from
vatican city ever
so it would be i think
this is going to come down to some
serious definitions
wait greatest greatest distance from am
i the only one dumb enough to not even
understand what the question is supposed
to be asking here
where commun where the communion was
given
and received how far
from vatican city that would be so it
has to be the question has to be about
word play
right i i guess so it's it's uh
so who's furthest farthest away from
vatican city when they received
communion i think i i think i actually
do have the answer to this
oh hold on apollo 11 moon landing there
it is
i was just i swear to this baby yeah you
were about to write cop down that on
there
i was just about to say the moon you
didn't give me a chance to break it down
this scientologist went back to her
catholic roots after divorcing
her movie star husband oh
i think i know this i know all the
celebrity questions
how embarrassing is this
who else was nicole kidman oh man i
picked the second wife
oh i'm completely wrong what did you i
said kate crews because i forgot her
last name but i thought it would be trad
to use his life i thought it was uh
what's her name leah remini from
the uh king of queens yeah used to be
scientologists and
i assumed she was catholic but i
actually think she didn't go back to
catholicism
though i think she's like stayed with
some like kind of weird weird view
all right all right well so much for
that one nicole
five countries with the largest
population of catholics
the five countries with the largest
number
or like largest percentage the la all
right we'll just say the largest number
um
okay most total number
i'm done
the answer is brazil mexico
the philippines the united states and
the country
of michael knowles imagination also
sometimes known as italy
all right i'll take three yeah i got u.s
brazil and uh
what was done in mexico he said that
right yeah you said mexico
all right all right that one's even even
money
what country has the largest percentage
of catholics by population
that's the vatican at a hundred percent
yeah a trick question
but you still go to hell for getting it
wrong wait a second is matt still
writing there
i wrote italy yeah all right i'll take
my vatican it's
i believe the country is actually is
isn't the country called the holy see
i put vatican in parenthesis just in
case back when
back when there was good political power
and you know it uh the holy see had the
papal states
there were there were even more people
but i guess the percentage was probably
the same
third century bishop sandini is known
for his beheading and consequent
carrying of his own head before finally
dying
what country is he the patron saint of
i like this guy first of all i do like
him yeah i
you know it reminds you that it it
doesn't matter how far you go it's the
first step that counts
okay well i've just got one completely
just a total dartboard guess
sandini
the country is france oh
i guessed syria because it sounded kind
of like i actually put syria too
it says something about our cultural
perceptions i think
how many books does the catholic bible
include
i'm gonna get this off by like one or
two
old and new testament i assume right
yeah
oh man i'm gonna get i'm definitely get
this wrong
the answer is 73 books
i put 72. i had 59 so
i was a little bit off yeah do we get
any relative points here or is that
ah man that's brutal and the bonus
question how many are in the protestant
bible
see this is a trick because if you get
it right then you lose a point that's
right this is the problem
unfortunately i think i know this one
huh wait i think i know what matt is
thinking of right now
it's 66. because
i'm actually ashamed to have gotten that
right i got 68. yeah i'm sorry that i
knew that
so you lose a point right i should
really lose all the points for getting
that right
what denomination is the lord of the
multiverse andrew clavin
oh we're kind of giving this one away
haven't we
i'll just leave you to answer that one
on your own because
it's so many different multiverses
there's so many different denominations
do we know what it was that actually is
i i actually do happen to know this
answer so he says he's anglican
he thinks anglo catholic but i think he
goes to a presbyterian church i wrote
eagle it's
him too but i i have no idea at all i
think that is the more correct answer
i think that's that's the one all right
there we have it
the better catholic is of course uh matt
walsh
but noel's got more answers right all
right
i am uh even more sure that i was right
to begin with about this whole
this whole idea so i i feel vindicated
in a way
in a way i feel vindicated you know at
the very least we were both
able to demonstrate our uh
embarrassing ignorance of our faith that
that's that's
and then it adds to the guilt and the
shame which makes us better catholics in
the end so i think we're all winners in
the end
that's a good point 45 you want to give
a 45 second commercial that's pretty
that's real money man that's pretty good
okay are we rolling
watch the michael knowles show it's a
great
show there are many things about it
that you might enjoy
if you were to watch it
if you were to watch it or even say
listen to it um we can watch and listen
to it
uh sometimes there are some who would
watch and then listen to it
listen and then watch it
both at the same time is the
michael knowles show this is a great
great show and i would just recommend
really watching
there you go i feel like i really nailed
that
uh thank you very much i appreciate it
you're welcome yeah absolutely
anytime uh make sure by the way that
everyone
out there in the internet's lands
sends in your next thoughts for the next
highly contentious
serious high stakes face-off